acht Monate Krieg liegen hinter dem
Menschen und Sie wissen nicht wie viele
noch kommen werden wenn kein Luftalarm
herrscht wenn keine Rakete oder Drohne
einschlägt dann bekommt man einen
Eindruck wie das Leben in Kiew sein
könnte wie es gewesen war
es ist Krieg und Normalität eine
Illusion
ich bin am Morgen aufgewacht weil ich
die Explosionen gehört habe
und dann habe ich mich einfach wieder
umgedreht
das war alles was ich getan habe
später habe ich dies meinen Freunden im
Ausland erzählt sie schwiegen für einen
Moment
dann sagten Sie Irina etwas völlig
abnormales ist mit deiner Psyche
passiert wenn du nicht mehr auf
Explosionen reagierst
deine Angst ist gebrochen
Luftalarm viele Menschen gehen jetzt
wieder in die Bunker in der Tiefgarage
um die Ecke hat sich eine
Schicksalsgemeinschaft eingefunden man
überbrückt die Zeit und alle warten auf
Entwarnung
André ist it-programmierer für
amerikanische Firmen er wisse nie
erzählt er wie er ihnen sein Leben unter
Luftangriffen erklären soll
wenn kein Luftalarm ist dann versuchst
du einfach dein normales Leben zu leben
du denkst alles ist in Ordnung
dann passiert es dann sind unsere Pläne
komplett zerstoben
in einem Montag wurde dieses Hochhaus im
Zentrum von Kiew getroffen das
benachbarte Kraftwerk dürfte wohl das
wahre Ziel des Luftangriffs gewesen sein
es versorgt das Viertel mit Energie
eine Woche später der nächste
Luftangriff auf dasselbe Kraftwerk es
trifft dieses Wohnhaus fünf Menschen
starben 19 konnten aus dem Trümmern
gerettet werden darunter diese alte Frau
drei Tage später treffen wir den Enkel
der alten Frau an gleicher Stelle er hat
im Fernsehen gesehen wie seine Oma
gerettet wurde sagte uns Filmen sei okay
vor der Kamera sprechen will er nicht es
gekommen um ihre persönlichen Sachen
abzuholen
das Gebäude ist einsturzgefährdet die
Bewohner können es nicht betreten und
ihre Sachen selbst herausholen
wir fahren in den Nordwesten von Kiew
dort treffen wir wollen die mir er ist
Germanist und schwärmt von deutscher
Literatur als die russische Armee
Richtung Kiew marschierte stand sie nur
wenige Kilometer vor seiner Wohnung und
volodemia mit seinen Freunden hier wache
meistens waren wir nicht bewaffnet also
einige der Jungs im Haus also es waren
ja mehrere mehrere also es gab ja mehr
als nur wir drei ja einige Jungs hatten
natürlich Küchenmesser und so weiter und
so weiter aber wirklich Schusswaffen
hatten wir nicht er hat Kiew während des
Krieges nicht verlassen kämpfen könne
ein Bücherwurm wie er nicht sagt er aber
Hilfe leisten er besorgt um was ihn
Soldaten an der Front gebeten haben das
ist
antistatisch Roll und Benzin beständig
die kommen glaube ich aus einem Lager
irgendwie in Frankreich oder so das sind
die anato Schuhe die die also solche
solche Art wird noch nicht gebraucht
aber unsere Jungs sagen das wäre das
beste
morgen will er alles an die Front fahren
700 km in den Osten
trotz stolz Hoffnung begegnet einem in
Kiew genauso wie schmerzleid und Trauer
all dies tragen die Menschen in sich
besser wenn meine letzten Worte frei
sind als dass ich bis zum Ende eines
langen Lebens schweigen muss das will
ich nicht für meine Kinder das will ich
nicht für meine Enkelkinder
ein Leben in Freiheit in Unabhängigkeit
dafür bringen viele Menschen in Kiew
große Opfer
[Musik]